>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Betsy Peterson:
Hello, everyone.
If I could ask you
all to take a seat
at this time, that
would be great.
My name is Betsy Peterson.
I'm the director of the
American Folk Life Center here
at the Library of Congress.
And on behalf of the staff,
indeed everyone in the library,
I want to welcome you today
to the latest presentation
in our Benjamin A.
Botkin lecture series.
The series allows us at the
center to highlight the work
of scholars in a range of areas
in the disciplines of folklore,
ethnomusicology, oral
history and cultural heritage,
while also enhancing
the collections here
at the America Folk Life Center.
Every lecture is
videotaped and becomes part
of the permanent archive.
And also each lecture is
later posted as a webcast
so that people throughout
the world and for generations
to come can hear the lecture
that you are going
to be hearing today.
So with all of that said now,
if you do have any electronic
devices, cell phones, et cetera,
on, please turn them
off at this point.
We are very proud to be the
American Folk Life Center,
but sometimes I know the
name gives people the wrong
impression or that our interests
and our archival
holdings are only limited
to American materials.
And that is not the case at all.
Of course, we're an
outstanding collection,
I would dare say the outstanding
repository for American music,
dance and traditional culture.
But among the more than 3,000
collections in our archive,
our materials from
hundreds of other cultures,
countries throughout the world
and in fact virtually all
of the reading rooms here at
the library contain collections
in multiple languages
from cultures
and countries throughout
the world.
In the Asian reading
room, for instance,
you can access the library's
South Asian collection
which relates directly
to our lecture today.
And I would just like to
acknowledge our colleagues
from the Asian reading
room today.
Welcome and thanks for coming.
The South Asian collection
in the Asian reading
room contains materials
from Bangladesh, Bhutan,
India, the Maldives, Nepal,
Pakistan and Sri Lanka.
The collection currently has
332,000 monograph volumes,
more than 1,000 active
journals and over 68,000 titles
on microfesh and provides
broad general research coverage
in most fields and disciplines,
but especially vernacular
languages in literature,
religion and philosophy,
politics, history and sociology.
And so today we will hear about
an ancient cultural tradition
that is practiced both in
India and the United States.
This afternoon, I
have the pleasure
of introducing the
distinguished ethnomusicologist
and performer Joseph
J. Palackal.
Dr. Palackal who is
originally from the Indian state
of Karela grew up in
the musical traditions
of the Siro Malabar Church and
is an Indic musicology singer
and composer, as well as
one of the foremost experts
on the musical traditions
of the Indian Christians.
The founder and president of the
Christian Musicological Society
of India, Dr. Palackal received
his PhD in ethnomusicology
from the Graduate Center of
the City University of New York
in 2005 for his research
on the Syriac
or Aramaic chant
traditions in south India.
His dissertation compared the
contemporary melodic practices
of the East Syriac, Chaldean
rite of the Siro Malabar Church
and the West Syriac rite
of the Oriental Orthodox
churches of south India.
In addition to his
work as a scholar,
Dr. Palackal is a noted
performer, writer,
composer and CD producer.
He made his New York
debut in 1990
with a guest appearance singing
a Christian devotional song
in Hindi in the off-Broadway
show Nonsense.
And he has also performed
at Lincoln Center
and Princeton University.
We are delighted that he is able
to come to the library today,
and I ask you to join me
in welcoming Dr. Palackal
for this presentation
on Syriac chants
and Aramaic Christianity
in India.
Dr. Palackal.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph J. Palackal: Thank you
for that wonderful introduction.
Let me begin by chanting the
Lord's prayer using almost the
exact words that Jesus
taught his disciples.
[ Chanting ]
With your permission, I would
like to dedicate this event
to the saintly Palackal
Toman Apan, my collateral
and sister who died in 1841.
He was a great teacher
of the Aramaic language,
and founder of the
seminary in his native town
and the first seminary
of the Sindar Christians.
And who founded the first Lis
congregation for men in India
to which I belong, the
Caramelites of Mary Immaculate.
It is a great honor to be here
to talk about the language
that he was so passionate
and he taught his disciples.
Almost for 1,000 years
the biggest export item
from India was religion.
And that religion
was not Hinduism.
It was Buddhism.
Ever since Emperor
Ahsoka accepted Buddhism,
he became the biggest promotor,
just like Constantine
did to Christianity.
And he sent missionaries to the
different parts of the world,
including Palestine
and the Middle East.
Emperor Ahsoka not only accepted
Buddhism but he also laid
out foundations for
respectful dialogue
and respectful other
religious traditions.
So by the time Christianity
came on the scene,
India had already prepared that
mindset to welcome anything
and everything without
contradicting but respecting.
So it is in this context
we talk about the movement
of the eastern religion
which became Christianity
to other parts of Asia,
to south India in Karela.
It is amazing that
Christianity we believe,
that Christianity
moved to south India.
Before the preaching
of Jesus, the charisma
of Jesus became a religion.
Jesus did not promote
a religion;
he lived a Jew, died a Jew.
He changed the perception
of his own mother faith
but eventually it
became a religion.
Before Christianity
became a doctrine religion,
the faith reached Karela.
We believe it came through
St. Thomas the Apostle,
one of the 12 apostles.
Because of the trade
relationship, spice trade,
the region was known to the
Middle East, so probably he came
in one of those ships.
In any case, they will
receive the simple faith,
and interestingly,
this is the man
who made the biggest
profession of faith
in just two words
in Aramaic language.
[Aramaic phrase],
my Lord and my God.
This was an exuberant outburst
when Jesus appeared especially
for him and asked him to touch
his hands and touch his side.
He came out with this profession
of faith [Aramaic phrase],
simple words, my
Lord and my God.
While the disciples
were doubtful, he said,
"You are man and God."
And it took 325 years and
the rise of a Roman emperor
to arrive at a simple
consensus on the exegesis
of these two words which we
have in the Nicaean Creed.
If you look at that creed,
how verbose, how difficult,
how much they have
been struggling to pin
down what St. Thomas the
Apostle said in two words.
So this faith in its
simplest form came to India.
And it survived there and in
due course they created poetry,
meaning they have connection
with the Middle East
in the Syriac Aramaic language.
The poetry that they were
singing celebrated the faith,
the simple faith.
I'm going to sing two lines
which expresses deep
Christological theology.
So this is part of a canonical
prayer literally the hours.
This is a couplet from a
long chant sung during Advent
and Christmas seasons.
But this particular couplet
when it comes to that couplet,
the liturgical book says
sing twice three times
because of the significance
of the text
which I will explain soon.
And the Siro Malabar
Christians began to take it
as a separate chant and sing it
in three ascending
pitch registers
and proclaim the faith.
[ Foreign language ]
We worship you, Lord.
[Foreign name] is God,
[foreign name] is divinity.
[Foreign name], you
are divinity.
[Foreign language]
and you are human.
[Foreign word] is man.
[Foreign word] humanity.
[Foreign phrase]
you're humanity.
The next phrase is the crucial.
[Foreign phrase] is
doubt or division.
Very clever play on the word.
[Foreign phrase] without
division, or without doubt.
While Christianity
was struggling,
in several ecumenical councils
to define how did humanity
and divinity in Christ
come together,
they were breaking their heads,
they were expounding
on the stories.
So you can imagine so many
things were happening.
St. Thomas Christians in India
were singing this couplet
which proclaimed
everything was resolved.
There was no problem.
Let me sing first and then
we will talk a little more.
[ Singing ]
There is another song that
again dissolves the cloud
of historianism that is hanging
over the St. Thomas
Christians ever
since the Portuguese
encountered them.
And that song is another
Grecian melody [foreign name].
Son of Mary, Son of Mary.
Mary gave birth to
the son of God.
So there was no problem.
There is no problem.
There is no need to fight
and kill each other.
It was already certain.
So they sang, "Son of
Mary, son of Mary."
Mary forgave for the son of God.
There was no confusion.
[ Singing ]
And they will sing
those two stanzas
and this will be the refrain.
The other stanzas go,
"Son of Mary did this.
Son of Mary promised a pardon.
Son of Mary sanctified
the waters of Jordan."
So everything is son
of Mary, son of Mary.
But that son of Mary
is the son of God.
So there was no confusion.
This was how they celebrated
faith, through chants.
There was no doctrinal
imposition.
It was part of their faith.
And at this moment I'd like to
bring in one Malayalam word,
how the word [foreign word]
which we translate
to English as faith.
The Karela people translated
it into Malayalam or maybe
into Tamur before
Malayalam became a language.
[Foreign word].
[Foreign word] is
breath, breath.
[Foreign word], that means
it is beautiful breath.
This is how they translated
faith in Malayalam.
It is part of the
breath of the people.
It is not just something
that you believe in.
It is not something
that you discuss.
It is not that something that
you arrive at the conclusion,
but it is your breath,
your own breath.
That idea of breath comes
from another word in Aramaic,
the meaning of which is
breath, which is [foreign word].
Which we translate awkwardly
in English as Holy Spirit.
[Foreign word] the
very breath of God.
The personification is the
third person of the trinity.
So let us leave that aside.
So this faith in India, among
the Christians in India,
St. Thomas Christians
celebrate it through their songs
and dances, and then
it continues.
And then every love
story has a villain,
like the Hindi movies
you have seen.
That villain came from Portugal.
So the missionaries came,
they encountered St. Thomas
Christians and they saw
that they were worshiping
in Syriac.
What kind of -- their idea
of Catholicism was different
from what they saw in the land.
So that came into conflict.
They said, "We have
to change this.
We have to change it to Latin."
But the St. Thomas
Christians said, "No.
This is the way of Thomas.
You follow the way of Peter.
And this is the language
of Jesus,
so we want to retain
this language."
So what happened?
They introduced Latin elements,
but they translated
them into Syriac.
So in the video we will
see examples of that.
Well, the villain went away but
then you know, it is amazing.
They went away, but a little bit
of that villain resurfaced
in the 1960s.
The people, St. Thomas
Christians,
the Siro Malabar Christians we
are talking about, they thought
that the language has
lost its credibility,
nobody knows Syriac.
So they changed, as it
happened, the Latin rite,
they changed everything into
Malayalam in the 1960s, 1962.
So this was before
the Vatican too.
It had nothing to do
with the Vatican too.
So the generation that was born
after that transition did
not know the language.
Slowly the language is
on death bed right now.
So it is in this context
that I come on the scene.
So when I came to New York to
do my PhD, I wanted a new topic.
And I grew up in the tradition.
I was an officer reading
Syriac in Malayalam script.
So when it came to the choice
of doctoral dissertation,
I chose Syriac chants
in south India
at City University of New York.
I had a great eminent
director, Dr. Steven Blount.
And then after doing that,
I also worked on a CD
of Syriac chants, and interest
came in and it continued.
So after PhD I continued
research on.
Because if someone didn't do
anything, this could die out.
So I started the
Aramaic project.
The result of that project is
what we are going to see now.
And the video has four sections.
It's a 22-and-a-half-minute
video.
It has four sections.
One is, why should we
take the Aramaic tradition
in India seriously?
So I talked to eminent people,
people who know better
than I do.
And we listen to their answers.
The second part is
how east meets west,
how St. Thomas Christians met
the Portuguese missionaries.
And during the interaction,
finally the Portuguese
missionaries succeeded
in convincing the
St. Thomas Christians
to accept their rituals
and practices
and translate the
chants into Syriac.
So that gave birth to a
new brand of Syriac music.
That is exclusively
the patrimony
of these Siro Malabar Christians
in Karela and nowhere else.
After watching the video, I
would like to have your comments
if you now something
similar elsewhere.
The third section of the
video is the transmission
of this tradition from
the older generation
to the younger generation,
what we are doing
with the Aramaic project.
And the fourth is our
attempt to reintroduce Syriac
into the vernacular liturgy.
Interestingly, I am so happy to
stand here and talk about that,
because the first time we did
that in America was not far
from here at the
Catholic University campus
at the Natural Shrine.
We had a celebration India
event and we celebrated mass
in the Siro Malabar tradition.
The cardinal came from India
and we introduced two Syriac
chants in that liturgy.
You will see examples from that
towards the end of the video.
You will see the
chant from there.
But it caught on.
Young people are catching
on, and I am so happy
that we have representatives
from Forest Church,
Virginia who just last Saturday
for their first communion,
they sang three Syriac chants
including the one I sang
in the beginning,
[foreign name].
I thought, "Wow."
For the first communion
kids, what else can you say?
Three years of catechism,
they compress into two lines.
[ Foreign language ]
We without doubt, we believe
in your divinity and humanity.
It's not just a piece of bread.
You are both man and God.
What a beautiful -- what
else do they need to say?
Looking at that piece of
bread, "You are man and God,
and we believe without doubt."
So in other words, this is
becoming part of America.
And that's how I'd like to
conclude this presentation,
by talking about some good news.
Complimenting about
two countries:
one my adopted country, America,
second my native country, India.
Once I finished my doctoral
dissertation, then I embarked
on this Aramaic project.
The first support came
from my own parishioners
and the local bank Mass
Preferred Savings Bank.
Even though they did not fully
understand what exactly what I
was embarking on, they
came forward and helped me
to launch the project.
And then to my surprise,
it caught on.
First example, is
Father Justin here?
Oh, thank you.
That is his parish,
and I thank you
for encouraging your
children to sing that.
We couldn't include
that in the video,
because it just happened
recently.
And at the priestly ordination
that took place a week ago
in New Jersey, they
sang Syriac chants.
Next week on June
3rd they are going
to sing Syriac chants during
a priestly ordination.
So it is catching.
This is becoming the
patrimony of this country.
It is becoming American.
That's a story of America.
It came from everywhere.
It found its own life here.
So that story is continuing.
That Aramaic language and
music is getting an American
face lift.
So some day it will become part
of the Christian experience
of the children here.
And finally, my native
country, India.
India from the beginning
welcomed ideas, ideologies
and even contradictory
ideas into its shore.
When we think of India, it's a
slightly different imagination
of a country from the
contemporary forces that want
to reduce India into a Hindu
country, a NATO perspective.
But India in my view
is not a country.
It is a concept, a
concept of coexistence.
India is like the river in
Herman Hess's Siddhartha.
Everything that flows
into it comes
into the shore and
becomes Indian.
It is fascinating.
Open to everybody,
welcoming everybody,
but converting it to Indian.
That nation, its philosophy,
let noble thoughts come
from anywhere, served as a
basis for the preservation
of this Aramaic tradition.
And it survived all this while,
and we are now making a
historical intervention
to make it happen, to keep it
going for the next generation
and the generation after.
So it is this great nation
with its open-mindedness,
gave the impetus.
Therefore I would like to
conclude this presentation
by saying [foreign
phrase], thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
>> We are in the [inaudible]
church of the Syrian tradition.
And this tradition
is [inaudible].
And also in our traditional
piety.
There are celebrations in
which even now the liturgy
of [inaudible] is used.
And in some places the use
of the Syriac language is
become more and more prevalent.
So I believe that this
tradition is to be kept up.
[ Inaudible ]
>> It's about the
transformation that has happened
in the pronunciation of
the incantation of words.
[ Inaudible ]
[ Music ]
[ Singing ]
>> Can you say the
Lord's Prayer in Aramaic?
>> Yeah.
>> Do it.
[ Foreign language ]
>> Can you say this
prayer in Aramaic?
[ Inaudible ]
[ Chanting ]
[ Music ]
[ Singing ]
[ Chanting ]
[ Inaudible ]
[ Music ]
[ Chanting ]
>> That was beautiful.
Very rarely do we listen to
this chant in a female voice.
Traditionally this is always
sung by the priest and singers
who used to be all men.
So it's wonderful to listen to
this chant in a female voice.
And what do you think?
What do you feel about this
chant when you sing it?
>> It's a very meditative
and mournful song?
>> Do you like it?
>> I do like it.
>> Why?
>> It reminds me of the
Gregorian chants which are some
of my favorite western music.
>> How do you compare it
to the Gregorian chant.
What is your reason for that?
>> There's this kind of
unstructured tempo to it.
Very natural flow of time.
>> Interesting.
Now given that opportunity, will
you learn more songs in Syriac?
>> Yeah, it will be interesting.
>> And when the time comes,
will you teach your children
these types of songs?
>> It's very hard to say,
but I would like to
think that I would.
>> Excellent.
[ Chanting ]
>> We will sing in Syriac,
brothers and sisters,
raise your voice to
glorify the living God.
[ Chanting ]
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph J. Palackal: We have
a few minutes for questions
and answers and comments.
Yes? Yes, please.
>> When the music is
written down, is it written
in a trunk type thing?
Like chanting?
>> Joseph J. Palackal:
This is an oral tradition.
>> Strictly oral?
>> Joseph J. Palackal: Strictly.
There were two attempts
to make notations,
but that never picked up.
People learn by listening and --
[ Chanting ]
Yeah, they just learn.
And it's amazing, now
that you mention it.
When I was in the service,
before that I have to mention,
acknowledge a very special
person, my director.
When I was in the minor
seminary, my father John Biyani,
for some reason, he
is here, some miracle.
And I mentioned him because
in the seminary work we did,
during prayers, canonical
prayers, you learn the melody,
you sing with those who know
and then gradually
pick up the memory.
In fact, our community
sings a 17-verse melody,
a stroph which is 17 versus.
And it's a tremendous musical
composition, but we learn it
by practice and it
becomes natural.
>> So there's no symbol that
suggests the up and down?
>> Joseph J. Palackal: No.
It just happens.
Yes?
>> This came from
Syria of course.
What's the story of
this language there now?
Does anybody have
any [inaudible]
in the Syriac language?
>> Joseph J. Palackal: I'm
glad you asked that question,
but the answer is a sad one.
The history of the
language is sad.
Because in the seventh century,
because of the Arabic invasion,
it was not like Karela.
There Arabic was imposed.
So the Syriac that you hear
from the Middle East now
sounds very different.
Even the [chanting], it must
have a different flavor there.
And the memory of the
language is dying out there.
Whereas in India, there was no
persecution either for the Jews
or for Christians,
so it survived.
So probably the history of the
language is redefined in India.
Some of the melodies may
be more intact in India
than in the Middle East.
Now not all the melodies came
from Syria or Middle East.
There are some melodies there,
especially the Portuguese
melodies were composed
in Karela.
There are very few
samples of that.
So Karela has its
own contribution
to the music history of India.
Yeah.
>> One question.
>> Joseph J. Palackal: Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
Oh good. I am glad you
asked that question.
Aramaic, Christian
Aramaic, is known as Syriac.
The Aramaic language was
a commercial language
for a long time.
Remember when Emperor
Ahsoka published the edicts,
Aramaic was one of
the languages.
Which means there are people
who knew only Aramaic
in the kingdom.
Because if you didn't know
the rules of the kingdom,
your head could be chopped off.
So just the way we do Chinese
in Chinatown in New York,
there were Aramaic inscriptions.
So that was a story there.
And then -- so it was already
in the history of the language.
And when Christianity came,
literature in Aramaic came
to be known as Syriac.
Political situations changed.
One major reason
is the translation
of the Septuagint in Greek.
So Syria Aram, Aramaic,
became Syriac.
And then it stayed on.
Now there's a move among
St. Thomas Christians
in many Syriac churches in
Karela to take out the Syrian
and make it Syriac, because
they don't want association
with Syria.
Rather, Syriac Christians.
Thank you for clarifying
that, yes.
Yes?
>> How about the Portuguese?
When they came to
India, did they try
to suppress and destroy history?
[Inaudible]
>> Joseph J. Palackal:
There is an element,
because they challenged us.
Basically they thought,
"This is not real."
So they wanted us to change
the language in the Latin
and chant and all that.
But we resisted.
So in the process, one group
broke away from that tradition
and said, "No, we don't have to
do anything with this people."
So those are the Akarbites,
the orthodox and all that.
But we, the Siro
Malabar Christians,
stayed with the Portuguese
but translated into Syriac
and kept the incantations.
So we adopted benediction
of the blessed sacrament,
we adopted [inaudible] and
we have songs for the --
the song that the children
sang in [inaudible] is --
[ Chanting ]
It's a hymn to the
blessed virgin.
Probably that was composed
when we started [inaudible]
and all that.
So we cannot say they
destroyed everything.
I wouldn't use that
word destroy.
They challenged us.
The Siro Malabar Christians
accepted the challenge
and translated it into
Syriac and moved on.
So in the history of
music, that became a bone
because we have a new
branch of music in India.
And after the Portuguese
left, we didn't do much
to revive the tradition,
and then we left it.
We cannot blame anybody
for what we are doing now.
I'm glad some of our
priests are stepping forward
to reclaim the Siro
Malabar Church.
Otherwise the next
generation will have zero.
So that Siro B stands
for Syriac language.
So I am glad for priests
like Father Justin
and his assistant Felix Simon.
They are trying to
bring it back.
And someday we will
study the history
of the language in America.
Amazing. Yes?
>> Question between the
history of the Catholic
versus the orthodox Jews.
Are there differences?
>> Joseph J. Palackal: Oh yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
The orthodox Christians
used west Syriac.
The Catholics, the
Siro Malabar, we use --
I cannot say Catholic because
Siro Malingula also use
west Syriac.
So the Siro Malabar Church,
these two churches --
there are eight churches
among Sindon Christians.
Two churches use
Chaldean Syriac.
So what I am singing, what you
heard here, the whole story
of Chaldean Syriac, east Syriac.
West Syriac, the
pronunciation is different.
The basic difference is
like British English
and American English.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes. Completely different
melodic repertoire.
They have a very
complex system of music.
It is much more complex
than this.
They have us practice
this singing,
one chant in eight different
melodies, octo arcos.
[Inaudible] Gregorian chant.
Same text for different seasons.
They sing in eight
different tunes.
Whereas in the eastern
Syriac tradition,
we sing same melody
with different text.
What a beautiful
complementarity.
That means we --
[ Chanting ]
We apply that to different
texts in the same major
for different liturgical
context.
So these are complementary
traditions.
It enriches the world.
But for example, to be specific,
eastern Syriac will say
[foreign phrase], Holy God.
[Foreign word] is God.
West Syriac will say
[foreign phrase].
[ Foreign language ]
Glory be to the father and
the son and the Holy Spirit.
[ Foreign language ]
Whereas we will say --
Such differences, yes.
This world of music,
Syriac music is more
complex than we think.
Thank you for that question.
Yes, please.
>> This really isn't
a musical question,
so I'm not sure I should ask it.
But I was struck by the fact
that in the church there seemed
to be many statues, but I didn't
see anything resembling the
icons that one sees in
the eastern orthodox
and of course many
oriental orthodoxies.
>> Joseph J. Palackal:
Good observation.
Because these are from
the Siro Malabar churches,
which was Latinized.
So most of the segments
are from that tradition.
That's why you see that.
Good observation.
Thank you.
>> Betsy Peterson: I want
to thank Dr. Joseph J.
Palackal again for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.